les pipelines sont devenues un enjeu
social économique environnemental majeur
à lui seul le projet énergie est de
transcanada représente 16 milliards
des sommes investies dans ses chantiers
lord sont énormes
ces grands projets d'infrastructure sont
ils à l'abri du crime organisé où il ya
de l'argent à faire des musulmans le
crime organisé n'est pas tellement droit
l'agent ce que vous entendez premier
d'écouté électronique
ce ne sont que quelques minutes permis
presque 2 millions de conversations
captées par la grc dans l' enquête
colisée on entend les crises auto junior
qui sera assassiné plus tard en pleine
rue en 2009 le fils du parrain de la
mafia discute avec un membre du cartel
des égouts l'entrepreneur joe borsellino
pas question ici de contrats municipaux
dès que du coup des goûts mais d'un
autre genre de tuyaux
ce qui intéresse la mafia au plus haut
point ce sont des pipelines la pâte
[Musique]
on sait à quel point la mafia a étendu
ses tentacules dans l'industrie de la
construction
et on a tous vu ces images
d'entrepreneurs échanger de l'argent ou
comme senza le quartier général du clan
rizutto pendant l'opération colisée de
la grc
joe borsellino ya été vu plusieurs fois
le second témoins récalcitrants devant
la commission charbonneau le dirigeant
de construction garnier a été
administrateur et actionnaire d'autres
entreprises moins connus du public
donc ce n'est pas quand ils subissent
est une compagnie de construction
faisaient du pôle de réparation iphone
l'entreprise obtient surtout des
contrats en ontario et dans l'ouest
son principal client et transcanada
lorsque questionné sur le sujet à la
commission charbonneau joe borsellino
nie toute implication du clan rizutto
dans son entreprise
bon même en partenaire silencieux ou
cachés one entre eux pour l'audi nous
dit qu'il n'avait pas sur ce même
territoire
c'est y avait pas de partenaire 10 août
au pourtant les appels captée par la grc
en 2005 révèle qu'au contraire joe
borsellino à de discussion d'affaires
continué avec nick rizzuto junior au
sujet de ce maître pathelin sur v6 nick
rizutto son rôle au sein de la famille
rizzuto c'était de blanchir l'argent de
la famille et deux de s'occuper aussi
dans un certain sens des intérêts dans
l'économie légitime de duke là d'autant
plus qu'en 2005
vito rizutto son père était incarcéré
donc son rôle à lui devenu d'un coup
plus important
[Applaudissements]
ou 2005 rizutto appel borsellino
les deux hommes discutent d'une
rencontre qui doit avoir lieu le
lendemain étonnamment on parle ici d'une
bande autochtone stèle de meyclub lake
en colombie-britannique
la banque vient d'acheter beaucoup
d'actifs dans sonic pit lane
le policier éric vecchio a analysé
l'écouté électronique
on parle de quelle participation
monsieur borsalino pourrait avoir dans
cette nouvelle compagnie l'a qui
seraient rachetés par la bande
autochtone depuis qu'elle s'est associée
aux autochtones la compagnie n'arrive
plus à trouver une banque pour assurer
son cautionnement
la mafia est toujours à l'affût
d'entreprises qui ont des problèmes
financiers ou quoi que ce soit ou qui
ont de la misère à se faire financer des
projets par les banques aux coulisses
nick rizutto prend part aux négociations
mais ce taux il est très au courant de
ce qui s'en vient et parti c'est
vraiment une stratégie à adopter envers
les autres partenaires vannes
les drm de monsieur hristo est ce parce
qu'il ya un intérêt pécuniaire d'un dans
la voiture si on reporte de d'intérêt
dans cette aventure où l'on voit pas
pourquoi il serait la sonnette
'pipeline' sauver 16 a été vendu depuis
à des intérêts américains
son président actuel était partenaire
d'affaires de joe borsellino à l'époque
aucun des deux n'a retourné nos appels
la bande autochtone assure n'avoir
jamais rien su de la présence de risotto
dans la sphère un troisième joueur un
dénommé stéphane est aussi impliquée
dans les nids de sièges stéphane
bélanger c'était quand même l'homme de
confiance de joe borsellino et du même
fait de monsieur riche tôt stéphane
bélanger ça ça vous dit quelque chose
stéphane bélanger oui lui avez-vous déjà
des relations d'affaires avec lui oui
vous avez un projet avec monsieur
bélanger
oui avec non moi je vois qu est-ce que
celle de sommeil oui c'est que j'étais
actionnaire avec stéphane bélanger
c'est juste ce que c'est
pourtant stéphane bélanger n'apparaît
nulle part comme actionnaire dans les
documents de l'entreprise mais son nom
ressurgir à plus tard et il n'y a pas
que joe borsellino qui discutent de
pipeline avec le clan rizutto son
concurrent aussi deux mois plus tard le
17 octobre le fils du parrain de la
mafia elle tony accurso les deux hommes
prennent le temps de parler météo
tony accurso reviennent
vraisemblablement d'une croisière sur le
touch
ensuite on passe aux affaires walter
martinez loup et dirigeants de
louisbourg pipeline une compagnie dont
tony accurso est le premier actionnaire
louisbourg construit des pipelines pour
une yungas enbridge et transcanada entre
autres partout au pays
le même mystérieux stefan est encore
impliqué dans les discussions
on discute ici à mots couverts d'un
arrangement entre la compagnie de
pipelines de tony accurso et celle de
joe borsellino et stéphane qui lui sert
d'intermédiaire
le fils du paraît et une entrée
d'arbitrer le jeu entre les deux
entrepreneurs un rôle lucratif qu'on a
vu son père jouer dans d'autres projets
comme l'a démontré la commission
charbonneau
on a vu que nick était de plus en plus
impliqués et on voyait aussi le désir le
grand désir de son père d'en faire une
personne clé au niveau de la
construction tony accurso s'est toujours
défendu d'être associés au crime
organisé
malgré nos demandes d'entrevue il n'a
pas voulu s'expliquer sur ces
discussions mais nous avons retracé
stéphane bélanger
oui j'aimerais parler monsieur stéphane
bélanger s'il vous plaît il travaille
toujours sur des chantiers de pipelines
auprès d'une grande compagnie et pas
n'importe laquelle il est merlan
gestionnaire chez transcanada monsieur
bélanger je vous appelle parce que votre
nom était évoqué à la commission
charbonneau
j'aimerais que vous m'expliquez votre
rôle dans ces histoires
selon la description de tâches produite
par transcanada stéphane bélanger gère
des contrats auprès de fournisseurs et
approuve des dépenses une position
délicate parce que même si le clan
rizutto était faibli au sein de la mafia
montréalaise
l'organisation reste active parce que la
mafia
une fois que tu as tu es tu à te fait
affaire avec le zoo directement ou
indirectement sur est ce toujours
vulnérable c'est clair que si monsieur
bélanger se retrouve sur un chantier de
construction toujours la possibilité
qu'ils soient utilisés ils peuvent
revenir dix ans plus tard de te rappeler
qu'il t'avait rendu un service et leur
aujourd'hui ont besoin de toi et ont
besoin d'un service
faut que tu rentres de service
informé des relations d'un de ses
gestionnaires avec le clan rizutto
transcanada nous a dit mener des
vérifications internes nous avons appris
que stéphane bélanger n'a pas contesté
l'avis de blâme que lui a fait parvenir
la commission charbonneau une fois pas
ignorer lui à qui parler l'autre et
c'est nicolo rizutto si tu ignores c'est
un peu on s'est un peu de l'aveuglément
volontaire je pense la mafia se sert de
ses relations pourraient filtrer des
entreprises légitimes avec ou sans leur
consentement
une manière de faire des gains
profitable et de blanchir de l'argent
sans laisser de traces de secrets de la
mafia ses sauts c'est son réseau de
contacts
autant dans ses activités illicites que
dans l'économie légale
les bribes d'écouté électronique devrait
alerter l'industrie des pipelines à
l'intérêt que lui porte le crime
organisé le crime organisé toujours
avant gardiste dans la la façon d'aller
chercher une part du gâteau
donc c'est pas surprenant qu'on veuille
exploiter ce réseau là puisqu'on le sait
qu'on voit investir des sommes
astronomiques dans le développement de
ses pipelines notre grille et pour
rassurer ni calmer la controverse à
l'aube d'importants projets au canada